if you want to know about how the
psychic powered Danny Torrance has in
the shining contributed to bringing
together the seven members of the losers
Club then stick around to the end of
this video
20-19 has been a very Stephen King full
year for movie fans there was a Pet
Sematary movie there's an it sequel and
there's a dr. sleep movie as well as an
adaptation for in the tall grass
when Pet Sematary was coming out I made
this video where I talked about how Elie
Creed has the shine the psychic
clairvoyance that dick hallorann tells
Danny Torrance about in The Shining it
wasn't in fact I'd go so far as to say
that all Stephen King characters have a
little bit of shine to them it's just
that some have a stronger case than
others it seems to be especially
prominent in children so what about the
kids from Kings 1986 novel it let's look
at some of the evidence when Halloran
explains the properties of the shine to
Danny Torrance the first thing he talks
about is the psychic connection members
of the losers clubs seem to have this
ability without explicitly knowing it
like just before Stan's encounter with
its when it has the idea that the
standpipe seems like it's floating that
was an odd thought he supposed it must
have come from his own head or else
could it come from but somehow it did
not seem like his own thoughts at all
another example is when Eddie breaks his
arm
Eddie falls asleep and dreams that his
friends came to see him at the hospital
and his mom tries to tell them off in
the waiting room a similar encounter did
occur in real life but it was on the
lawn of the dairy home hospital not in
the waiting room when Eddie wakes up he
somehow knows that what his mom said to
his friends was real and he's upset with
her for heads like a girl sleep and he
shows me things but when I wake her
can't remember another property of the
shine is the ability to see past and
future events in the shining Tony shows
Danny the dangers that await him at the
Overlook Hotel
respect you can see things that haven't
happened yet well sometimes they can
happen in it's bill senses that
something bad is gonna happen before the
rock fight against the Bowers gang and
before they open the fortune cookies as
adults there are a couple of other
examples where they're able to
anticipate future events as well as one
notable example of seeing into the past
just like Dani is able to see the
murders that took place in the Overlook
Hotel Richie and Mike are able to see an
event that took place in the Barrens
millions of years ago during the smoke
hole ritual
another ability that's implied about the
shine is the ability to sense someone
else's feelings this one might be a
little bit harder to prove because as
humans we're able to read each other's
emotions to some degree based on how
somebody acts but there are a couple of
instances where Bill is able to sense
what it is feeling without even being in
the same room as it for example after
the incident with the photo album bill
first gets the idea that it is scared of
them and he has this feeling again after
finding the death threat left on the
fridge in the junkyard
it's scared of us you know he said I can
feel that that I swear to God I can on
that note the fact that it is even
afraid of these kids at all when it's
been alive for millions of years and
killed hundreds of people could speak to
the fact that it knows that the shrine
is strong with them and realizes the
danger that this poses it which brings
me to my next point
the final battle that the losers have
with it as both kids and adults is a
telekinetic showdown known as the ritual
of chode as a kid bill is knocked
outside of his physical body into a void
and known as the macro verse where he
must take hold of its metaphysical
tongue in order to hurt it as adults
bill tries to do this again but missus
is shocked
so Ritchie joins in and mentally grabs
on to it causing it immense pain to the
point where it begs Ritchie to let go
let me go let me go and you can have
anything you've ever wanted money fame
fortune power I can give you these
things so the losers can use this
telekinetic energy as a weapon this
power can cause physical damage to a
person and we see the same thing happen
in
shining in Chapter 11 Halloran is trying
to gauge how powerful Danny shine is and
asked him to give a blast of thought as
hard as he can thing describes it as
coming in like a Nolan Ryan fastball hi
dick hallorann winced and jerked back
word on the seat his teeth came together
with a hard click drawing blood from his
lower lip in a thin trickle his hands
flew up involuntarily from his lap to
the level of his chest and then settled
back again for a moment his eyelids
fluttered limply with no conscious
control and Danny was frightened mr.
Halloran dick are you okay I don't know
Halloran said and laughed weakly i
honest to god don't the same thing
happens later in the book when Danny's
in trouble and tries to call out today
who's in Florida
using the shine the reason Danny is in
trouble is because he and his father
Jack are strong shiners so they're able
to see the evil in the hotel they can
see all of the ghosts of the overlooks
past but most people come into the
overlooking never have an issue in the
movie there hasn't been an incident in
the last 10 years I don't suppose they
told you anything in Denver about the
tragedy we had up here during the winter
in 1970 I mentioned before that most
people who shine tend to be kids and in
Derry kids are the biggest targets of it
people tired disappear six times the
national average
and that's just grown-ups kids are worse
way way worse then there's the fact that
it seems to be mostly kids who can see
it or the effects of it's like the blood
that comes out of the drain that
Beverly's parents can't see but the rest
of the losers Club can or the blood that
comes out of Georgie's photo album that
his parents can't see but he and Richie
can there are a few adults who are able
to see it but for the most part it's
something that kids have to deal with on
their own as exemplified by the
skateboard kid that bill meets who is
surprised that Bill believes the story
about Tommy the Kansa seeing a shark fin
in the canal like I said I think
everyone has some degree of shine to
them Halloran says he tried shining to
mrs. Torrance and she just jumped the
tiniest bit but maybe the reason that
the seven members of the losers Club are
so drawn to one another is not just that
they're all bullied by Henry Bowers but
rather that they all have a strong shine
to them whether they know it or not and
that's the reason that they all become
close at one point in the novel there
was another kid that they hung out with
called the Bradley Donovan but he ended
up getting in an argument with Ben after
accusing Beverly of cheating at the game
that they were playing he never comes
back around after that maybe he was
partially ashamed about what happened
but I think that he just didn't fit in
with the others because he didn't have a
strong shine like they did there's even
a moment where Beverley almost seems to
make this conclusion in her own cloth
but after a moment's hesitation it
Beverly did tell because somehow Stanley
was different from Bradley he was there
in a way Bradley had not been before I
throw to the end cards let me leave you
with one more thought the shining and
its share one common character and that
is dick Halloran who's located in Derry
in the year 1930 as a cook at the black
spot nightclub but eventually leaves to
become the head chef at the Overlook
Hotel in Colorado far away from Derry
Maine could it be that because of its
dairy is just about the scariest place
in the world to live because those who
shine like dick can see the atrocities
that occurred there on a daily basis let
me know your thoughts on all that in the
comments there's more that you have to
know about the shine so watch my theory
on how another Stephen King character
Elie Creed also has a strong case of it
by hitting the video on the left
remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
you